Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. His face floods with light and relief. You have won second prize in a beauty contest. Collect £10. Monopoly, first invented as the Landlords' Game in 1903, endlessly reimagined and reinterpreted ever since. Welcome to The Rest Is History with the old Kent Road of history, Tom Holland,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。他的脸上洋溢着光彩与释然。你在选美比赛中获得了二等奖，请领取10英镑。《大富翁》最初于1903年作为“地主游戏”被发明，此后不断被重新构思和诠释。欢迎收听《历史的余味》，我是“历史版肯特路”汤姆·霍兰德，
and with me, Mr Mayfair, Dominic Sandbrook. Hello, Tom. You're a big Monopoly fan? What a wonderful introduction. You've won the game of the rest is history already. I have. We should stop right now. It'll be downhill from there. So today's subject is a huge one, actually, isn't it? It's history as entertainment, history as board games, video games. And I thought we'd go in first with reenactments,
还有我，“梅菲尔先生”多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。你好，汤姆。你是《大富翁》的忠实粉丝吗？多么精彩的开场白。你已经赢得了《历史的余味》这场游戏。我赢了。我们现在就该结束了。再往下就该走下坡路了。所以今天的主题其实非常宏大，不是吗？它是作为娱乐的历史，作为棋盘游戏、电子游戏的历史。我想我们先从历史重演开始，
because that's obviously something that you know a lot about, because you've written about it in the past. And we had a question to me from Roland Miners, who says, I seem to remember the Romans did battle reenactments as part of their games. So we're always told that the stadiums could be flooded for sea battles. And he says, was this a bit of theming for gladiators to kill each other, or was this actual reenactment of history? And I guess for as long as there's been history, Tom, people have reenacted it, right?
因为这显然是你非常了解的事情，因为你过去写过关于它的文章。我们收到了罗兰·迈纳斯发来的一个问题，他说，我似乎记得罗马人在他们的竞技比赛中进行过战斗重演。我们总是被告知体育场可以注水进行海战。他问，这只是角斗士互相残杀的一种主题包装，还是真正的历史重演？我想，只要有历史存在，汤姆，人们就在重演它，对吧？
Yeah, well, people probably remember in Gladiator that Russell Crowe plays the part of the Carthaginians in the Battle of Zama, where the Carthaginians lost to the Romans, but in Gladiator they win, which, of course, is part of the fun of reenacting history isn't it i mean it's part of the fun of staging these is that occasionally uh you get different results so we obviously the romans would have exercised some control over that so we know for instance that after claudius conquers britain he restages his um his capture of colchester there was no question that the britains were going to win that. Obviously, the Romans had to win it. But yes, I think you do get the sense.
是的，人们可能记得在电影《角斗士》中，罗素·克劳在扎马战役中扮演迦太基人，在那场战役中迦太基人输给了罗马人，但在《角斗士》中他们赢了，这当然是重演历史的乐趣所在，不是吗？我的意思是，举办这些活动的部分乐趣在于，偶尔你会得到不同的结果。所以我们显然知道罗马人会对这些进行某种控制，比如我们知道克劳狄皇帝征服不列颠后，他重演了他占领科尔切斯特的过程，毫无疑问，不列颠人是不可能赢的。显然，罗马人必须获胜。但是的，我想你确实会有这种感觉。
We know that Claudius also sponsored a great naval battle in which I think the Rhodians and the Syracusans fought each other. And I think that's a bit more like those kind of computer games where you can get the Aztecs fighting the Babylonians or something. You bring different people to fight each other. And, of course, in this style of armour that the gladiators wore, so that you had a type called the Samnite, which was a central Italian people defeated by the Romans
我们知道克劳狄还赞助了一场伟大的海战，我想是罗得岛人和叙拉古人互相交战。我觉得这更像那种电脑游戏，你可以让阿兹特克人与巴比伦人对战之类的。你把不同的人带到一起互相战斗。当然，角斗士穿的盔甲风格也是如此，比如有一种叫“萨姆尼特人”的类型，这是被罗马人击败的中意大利民族，
kind of in the 3rd century BC. And then you have Thracians, who were another kind in Northern Greece. And I think there was the sense with gladiatorial combat that it was about reminding the Romans of their own history, of their martial qualities. You know, Rome is this city
大约在公元前3世纪。然后还有色雷斯人，这是北希腊的另一种类型。我认为角斗士格斗有一种感觉，那就是提醒罗马人关注他们自己的历史，关注他们的尚武品质。你知道，罗马是这个伟大和平帝国的心脏。所以人们确实有点担心他们正在忘记自己的尚武价值观。因此，我认为角斗士格斗在某种意义上是为了提醒罗马人记住他们古老的尚武历史。所以，是的，我认为在某种程度上你可以将其视为历史重演。而且讲述历史本身就是一种重演，不是吗？
at the heart of a great peaceful empire. So people did slightly worry that they were forgetting their martial values. So there was, I think, a sense in which gladiatorial combat existed to remind the Romans of their ancient martial history. So was, I think, a sense in which gladiatorial combat existed to remind the Romans of their ancient martial history. So, yeah, I think you could count that as historical reenactment to a degree. And sort of telling history in itself is a reenactment, isn't it?
我的意思是，关于历史奇怪的一点是，当你把它写在纸上重述时，你其实是在表演它。历史总是存在这个问题。你知道，我们在推特上收到了很多关于历史在多大程度上是社会科学，或者在多大程度上是一种文学娱乐的评论？而娱乐从一开始就融入了历史之中，
I mean, the weird thing about history is that, you know, you're sort of performing it when you retell it on the page. And there's always this issue with history. You know, we get a lot of comments on Twitter about, you know, it when you retell it on the page. And there's always this issue with history. We get a lot of comments on Twitter about to what extent is history social science or to what extent is it a kind of literary entertainment? And entertainment is kind of baked into history
比如希罗多德等等。人们阅读那些东西是因为它很有趣，因为他们想获得乐趣。但你不觉得，当你阅读关于过去的东西时，你内心深处也有一种渴望，想要亲眼看看它吗？哦，绝对是，绝对是。所以我们谈到了亚瑟王，谈到了温彻斯特的圆桌，那几乎可以肯定是爱德华一世统治下的骑士们为了重现卡美洛而建造的，那是一个
from the beginning, isn't it, with Herodotus and so on. And people read that stuff because it's fun and because they want to have fun. Don't you think also, though, that baked into it is a kind of, when you read something about the past you you can feel this yearning to see it for yourself oh absolutely yeah absolutely and so you know so we talked about arthur we talked about king arthur and the round table at winchester which almost certainly was built to mark an attempt by knights under edward i to recreate um camelot and that was
主题，你知道，那是整个中世纪锦标赛的一个主题，人们会打扮成加拉哈德或兰斯洛特之类的角色，这是一种想要让这种人们相信确实发生过的浪漫世界变得真实的渴望。他们和我们一样，有一种对失落世界的感知，那是他们永远无法找回的。是的。而且他们认为过去是迷人的，是吗？是的。当然，最著名的是维多利亚女王加冕后，人们试图重现锦标赛，因为很多人觉得那次加冕相当沉闷。他们废除了那种传统，即女王的冠军出场，如果有人不接受她为女王，就挑战其进行单挑。
something you know so that's that was a theme in tournaments throughout the middle ages was that people would come dressed as you know galahad or lancelot or whatever and it was a kind of desire to make real this world of of of romance that people believed you know had actually happened they had a sense as we do of a kind of lost world that they can never recapture. Yeah. And gamma. They think that the past is glamorous, do they? Yes. And then, of course, famously, there was an attempt to recreate the tournament in the 19th century after Queen Victoria's coronation, which lots of people felt had been rather drab. And they got rid of this kind of tradition where the champion of the queen comes in and challenges someone to single combat if they're not going to accept her as queen.
于是埃格林顿伯爵在艾尔郡举办了这场锦标赛，当然，结果下雨了。当然。所以这完全是一场彻底的失败。但那种维多利亚时代的“伪中世纪主义”潮流其实很精彩，它对建筑和各种事物都产生了巨大的影响，但他们确实尝试过举办锦标赛，我想这绝对是延续到20世纪的事情，因为当然，消费社会越发达，你有越多的钱可以花在重现这些东西上，人们就越会去做。是的，我想我记得
And so the Duke of Eglinton set up this tournament in Ayesha, which, of course, it rained. Of course. So it was all in the absolute kind of washout. But that's kind of brilliant, that whole kind victorian strain of cod medievalism yeah which was hugely influential on architecture and all kinds of things but it was you know they they did actually try and stage a tournament and i guess that that is absolutely something that goes into the 20th century because of course the more that you have a consumer society the more you have money that you can spend on recreating this kind of stuff the more people do it yes and i suppose there's a i remember
曾经和一位叫伊恩·莫蒂默的人交谈过，他写了那些名为《时间旅行者指南》的书，涵盖特定时期，他会把历史写得像旅游指南一样，你知道，这是你住的地方，这是你吃的地方。这关乎历史作为娱乐的问题，有时作为一名学术历史学家，当你与同行进行史学争论时，很容易忘记人们接触历史的原因，以及人们收听这个播客的原因，其实是因为它很有趣，因为你是在说这个播客很有趣。好吧，我想即使别人不觉得，我反正觉得很有趣。
having a conversation once with a guy called ian mortimer who writes these books called the time travelers um guide to a particular period and he'll write about history as though it's a guidebook you know this is where you stay this is where you eat and it was about the question about history as entertainment and sometimes it's easy to forget i think when you're a sort of academic historian um engaged in historiographical arguments with your peers that actually the reason people get into history and the reason actually people are listening to this podcast is because they is because it's fun it's because there's something you're saying this podcast is fun well i think I think I'm having fun anyway, even if nobody else is.
但是，你知道，那种你对历史感兴趣的感觉，不仅仅是因为它有启发性。我的意思是，我们做过一整期关于历史教训的播客，但正如你所说，有一种贪得无厌的，我是说字面意义上贪得无厌的渴望，想要看到我们之前的人，看到他们那个我们永远无法触及、完全遥不可及的世界。这就是为什么人们总是会做这些重演之类的活动。但当谈到重演时，其实有一个边界地带，不是吗？它变成了“生活历史”，人们会说，如果你想理解某件事，
But, you know, there's that sense that you're interested in history, not just because it's instructive. I mean, we've done a whole podcast about the lessons of history, but because, as you said, there is this sort of insatiable, I mean, literally insatiable yearning to see people who've been before us and to see their world that we can never that is completely out of reach and that's why people will always do these kind of reenactments and things but when it comes to reenactment there is actually a kind of border zone isn't it where it becomes a living history and people will say that um if you want to understand something you
你实际上必须去体验它。所以，几年前，在谈到中世纪锦标赛并重现它们时，我发现通常当你去国家信托基金会（National Trust）看他们重现时，我觉得非常无聊，因为它们只是摆拍。但大约五年前，我去了，
actually have to experience it so i yeah about years ago, talking on the subject of medieval tournaments and recreating them, I find generally when you go to, they recreate them at National Trust. I find incredibly dull because they're just staged. But about five years ago, I went to,
我想它正式名称叫“中世纪战争”之类的。它有点像一项运动。他们在西班牙中部拉曼查的一座城堡贝尔蒙特举办了它，那里是拍摄查尔顿·赫斯顿电影《熙德》的地方。是的。他们举办了一场巨大的国际锦标赛。
I think it's officially called Medieval Warfare or something. It's kind of like a sport. And they staged it at this castle, Belmonte, in La Mancha, in the middle of Spain, which is where they filmed El Cid, the Charlton Heston film. Yeah. And they have this huge international tournament.
它有点像世界杯。他们有来自美国、英国、德国，世界各地的队伍。我以为它又会非常无聊。结果非常精彩。它绝对太棒了。所以规则是他们有一个类似足球场的地方，你不能走出足球场。
It's kind of like the World Cup. They had teams from America and Britain and Germany, all around the world. And I thought it was going to, again, be really dull. It was brilliant. It was absolutely fantastic. So the rules are that they have a kind of like a football pitch, I guess, and you're not allowed to go outside the football pitch.
你们进行一对一、五对五的对抗。高潮是百人对百人。100个人。那就像是一场真正的战斗。哦，它真的很棒，这是我参加过的所有伟大的体育赛事之一。规则本质上是你可以随心所欲地拍打任何人的头部，你知道，你没有剑，你没有任何锋利的东西，但你有钝斧或钉头锤之类的，你可以直接拍打别人，
And you map up, you know, one-on-one, five-on-five. The climax was 100-on-100. 100 people. That's like, that's a proper battle. Oh, it was really really great it's one of the all great sporting events that i've ever been to and the rule is essentially that you can smack anyone around the head you like you know you don't have a sword you don't have anything sharp but you have kind of blunt axes or maces or whatever and you can just smack people
只要他们还站着，战斗就继续。一旦他们身体的任何其他部位触地，比如手、肘或头之类的，他们就出局了。这太令人惊叹了。而这具有教育意义的论点是，
and as long as they are on two feet, the battle continues. The moment they touch anything else, say with their hand or their elbow or their head or whatever, then they're out. And it was amazing. And the argument for this being educational
你的盔甲越好，你就越能站得住。所以我采访了德国队的队长，我想他是个旅行社职员，但在业余时间，他会走遍德国各地的教堂，观察骑士的盔甲雕像。寻找技巧。这太有趣了。但另一个精彩之处在于，它也非常、非常政治化。因为我认为这项运动是由俄罗斯人发起的。而俄罗斯人显然相当激进。
was that the better your armour, the better you are able to stand up. So I spoke to the captain of the German team who, I think he was a travel agent, but in his spare time, he'd go around chapels and churches all round Germany looking at effigies of knights in armour. Looking for tips. It was such fun. But also the other brilliant thing about that was that it was also very, very political. Because I think that this sport had been begun by the Russians. And the Russians were apparently rather aggressive.
所以他们被所有其他国家拒之门外。事实上，我想其中一些参与者后来还参加了克里米亚的入侵。这很有趣，是的，这本身就是一种对沙皇荣耀的重演。我的意思是，在某种程度上，政客们，鲍里斯·约翰逊是某种丘吉尔的重演吗？我的意思是，我想你可以说重演本身就融入了政治之中。但关于政治，这真是一件有趣的事情，因为你去过法国那个叫“狂人国”（Puy-du-Fou）的地方吗？
And so they'd been frozen out by all the other countries. In fact, I think some of the people who were involved in that then went on to take part in the invasion of Crimea. That's interesting yeah which is itself a kind of reenactment of czarist glory you know i mean to what extent politicians is boris johnson a kind of churchill reenactment act i mean uh that's i suppose you can argue reenactment is baked into politics itself but But on the politics, that's a really interesting thing because have you ever been to this place in France called Puy-du-Fou,
它是欧洲最受欢迎的主题公园之一，全部关于历史？没有，我去过阿斯泰利克斯公园。我没去过阿斯泰利克斯公园，但“狂人国”那个非常迷人，因为它有一系列区域。有一个关于维京人的，有几个关于中世纪的，你会喜欢的，
which is one of Europe's most popular theme parks, which is all about history? No, I've been to the Asterix Park. I've never been to the Asterix Park, but the Puy-du-Fou one is fascinating because it has a series of zones. There's one about the vikings there's one about there's a couple about the middle ages they have which you would love
他们有一个罗马圆形剧场，我的意思是，他们有一个圆形剧场，在那里他们表演战车比赛、角斗士战斗和野生动物节目。手册上说他们有处决表演，但我认为那不可能是真的。但这在那个地方非常受欢迎。它吸引了成千上万，数百万的人。它是法国仅次于迪士尼乐园的第二大访问量主题公园。有趣的是，它是由一位最初是密特朗文化部长的政客菲利普·德·维利耶建立的，他现在非常右翼，非常反伊斯兰、反移民，
they have a roman amphitheater i mean they have an amphitheater where they have shows with chariot racing gladiatorial battles and and wild animals um it says in the brochure they have executions but i don't believe that can be true um but it's massively popular in this space. It gets hundreds of thousands, millions of people. It's the second most visited theme park in France after Disneyland. And what's interesting about it is it's set up by a politician who was originally Mitterrand's culture minister, Philippe de Villiers, who's now very right-wing, very anti-Islam, anti-immigration,
是一个毫不掩饰的法国民族主义者、保守派。你得到的历史版本是纯粹的国王和战争。它是法国版的《我们的岛屿故事》。所以有关于黎塞留的火枪手的内容。他们有一个关于一战凡尔登战役的节目。而且它非常受欢迎。我的意思是，很难想象。你去过那里吗？
kind of an unashamed French nationalist, conservative. And the version of history that you get is kind of pure kings and battles. It's a kind of the French equivalent of Our Island Story. So there's stuff about Richelieu's musketeers. They have a thing about the Battle of Verdun from World War I. And it is colossally popular. I mean, it's hard to imagine. Have you been to that?
我其实没去过。我正谈论着它——我在新冠疫情前打算去。我儿子非常想去，我们偶尔在封锁期间为了自娱自乐，会看视频。你知道，那种糟糕的——关于处决的。以第三手游客的方式。我们会看别人去过那里的YouTube视频，
I haven't actually. I'm talking about it with – I was going to go before COVID. My son is desperate to go, and every now and again to amuse ourselves during lockdown, we would watch videos. You know, in that sort of terrible sort of – Of executions. Third-hand tourist way. We'd watch YouTube videos of other people who've been
然后为我们自己去不了而哭泣。我的意思是，它看起来很棒，但我当时在想，你能以一种不那么右翼的方式来做吗？我的意思是，你能做一个左翼的历史主题公园吗？我不确定他们是否做过彼得卢大屠杀的重演和关于宪章运动的事情。我的意思是，托尼·本会喜欢的，但他们在伯福德有“平均地权日”（Level a Day），
and sort of weeped that we can't go ourselves. I mean, it looks amazing, but I was thinking, could you do it in a less right-wing way? I mean, could you do a left-wing history theme park? And I'm not sure if they did a sort of Peterloo reenactment and a thing about the Chartists. I mean, Tony Benn would like, but they have Level a Day in Burford,
那是一种大型重演。我的意思是，重演是指人们带着海报出现，大喊关于约翰·利尔本之类的事情。好吧，我的意思是，有“密封结”（Sealed Knot）组织，不是吗？我想我能看出你作为一个50岁的人，你参加过“密封结”吗？我敢打赌你参加过。好吧，我记得我从来没有，不，我从来没有真正参加过，但我一直有一种秘密的渴望。是的。你会成为一名骑士（Cavalier），对吧？不，我会成为一名铁骑军（Ironside）。你会吗？
which is a kind of big reenactment. I mean, it's a reenactment as in people turn up with posters and shout about john lilburn or something well i mean there's a sealed knot isn't there which is yeah i think i can see you as a 50 years old man have you done the sealed knot i bet you've done the sealed knot well i i remember i've never no i've never actually taken part in it i always have a secret yearning. Yeah. You'd be a cavalier, though, wouldn't you? No, I'd be an Ironside. Would you?
我会成为一名铁骑军。我很想那样做。我想成为，比如，你可以成为克伦威尔的间谍头子之类的吗？那才是我想要的。也许是弥尔顿。就坐在那里装瞎，用拉丁语写些粗鲁的东西。有一本书，一部小说，由一位叫安东尼·普莱斯的犯罪小说家所写，我不知道还有没有人读它们，但我真的很喜欢，它们总是围绕历史展开的犯罪故事、惊悚片、间谍故事，他有一部
I'd be an Ironside. I'd love to do that. I'd like to be like, can you be Cromwell's spymaster or something? That's what I'd want to do. Milton, perhaps. Just sit there being blind, writing rude stuff in Latin. There was a book, a novel, by a crime writer called anthony price who almost i don't think anyone reads them anymore but i really love them they're always crime stories thrillers espionage stories revolving around history um and he had
叫《战争游戏》，背景设定在一种“密封结”式的战斗中。其中的要点是，议会派的所有人都非常左倾，而保皇派的所有人都非常右倾。一个被军情五处跟踪的非常左翼的家伙最终死在沟里，肚子上插着一把戟。听起来很棒，而且确实很棒。我记得它很棒，然后它变成了一个巨大的阴谋论。但我当时在想，如果你是左翼，你可能会被圆颅党吸引，如果你是右翼……因为我查了“密封结”，因为我想我们最终可能会谈论
one called war game which was set in the context of a battle a kind of sealed knot type battle and the gist in that was that everyone on the parliamentarian side was very much on the left and everyone on the uh royalist side was very much on the right and um a kind of a very left-wing guy who's being shadowed by mi5 ends up dead in a ditch with a halberd through his stomach um sounds great and it was great i remember it being great and uh and then it kind of you know turns out to be a big conspiracy theory um but i was kind of wondering whether i guess that um you know if you're on the left you would be probably drawn to the the round heads and if you're on the right because i because i looked up the the seal not because i thought we'd probably end up talking
它，上面说，这个协会的名字来源于护国公时期策划恢复君主制的一个团体。所以这是一个保皇派协会，但相似之处仅止于此，因为目前的协会——网站上用大写字母写着——是非政治性的，没有任何政治倾向或野心。所以“密封结”似乎非常重视澄清这一点。我可以相信他们，但同时，我认为作为一个重演者，在性格上可能确实有点保守，你不觉得吗？
about it and it says um the name of the society derives from a group which during the protectorate plotted for the restoration of the monarchy so it's it's a cavalier society but it's very here the similarity ends as the present society and this is in capitals on the website, is non-political and has no political affiliation or ambitions. So it seems very important for the SEAL not to make that clear. I can believe that of them, but at the same time, I think there probably is something temperamentally small because he's conservative about being a re-enactor, don't you think?
我的意思是，如果你是极左翼，你可能认为你想做的是建设一个更美好的明天，而不是回到过去，戴上一顶漂亮的帽子之类的。我认为，我不是说帽子本身有什么保守的，但那种感觉确实存在，不是吗？绝对是的，特别是如果上面有羽毛的话。但你看，我想重塑，我想打扮成斯坦利·鲍德温之类的，所以这可能相当……当然，标准……好吧，我认为那是一个巨大的摇钱树，我认为你应该继续那样做。是的，我的意思是，当然，因为在最极端的边缘，你确实是在进入一些相当可疑的领域。比如哈里王子，是的，哈里王子打扮成纳粹，所以打扮成纳粹是
I mean, if you're super left-wing, you probably think what you want to do is build a better tomorrow rather than go back to yesterday and sort of put on a nice hat and stuff um which i think is i'm not saying there's something inherently conservative about hats but that kind of is there isn't it definitely yes particularly got feathers in yeah but you see i'd want to reinvent i'd want to dress up as stanley baldwin or something so it would probably be quite of course the standard well i think that's a massive money spinner i think you should go ahead with that yeah well there's i mean of course because at the at the furthest extremes um you really are pushing into some quite dodgy areas so prince harry well yes so prince harry dressing up as nazis so dressing up as nazis is
大忌，可以说是被禁止的。大约10年前有一位国会议员里奇·阿亚特，我想他当时正在竞选国会议员，他的候选资格因为被发现是一名重演者而告吹。在他参与的重演中，他穿过党卫军制服。是的，我想那很难翻身。所以穿上党卫军制服，我想，我的意思是，你做得太过分了。人们总是声称，他们只是喜欢那套制服。
the big it's verboten as it were so there was a congressman rich ayat about 10 years ago i think he was um he was running for for congress and um his candidature got torpedoed because it turned out that he was a reenactor. And among the reenactments he'd done, he dressed up in SS uniform. Yeah, I think that's hard to come back from that. So dressing up in an SS uniform, I think, I mean, you're pushing the boat out there. The claim that people always make, isn't it, is they just like the uniform.
但是，是的，有一种“我们是坏人吗”的微妙感觉，我认为这很难克服，你不觉得吗？所以我也在那种背景下想，我不知道这个问题的答案，目前美国内战战斗重演的现状如何，因为我知道那是美国的一个巨大场景。我的意思是，他们让“密封结”看起来像业余爱好者。
But yeah, there's a slight are we the baddies aspect to it that I think is hard to overcome, don't you? And so also I was wondering in that context what, and I don't know the answer to this, what the state of play is at the moment with the re-enactment of battles in the American Civil War, because I know that that's a huge scene in America. I mean, they make the sealed lot look like amateurs.
我的意思是，他们确实是业余爱好者，但你知道我的意思。这规模很大。但我怀疑这是否涉及到一个我们应该在单独的播客中讨论的主题，那就是“南方邦联的迷途”（Lost Cause of the Confederacy）。所以很多人喜欢，我的意思是，对内战的迷恋，我认为在美国往往有一种政治维度，就像种植园和所有那些东西的整个生态系统一样。是的，我的意思是，作为一个局外人，很难。我的意思是，
I mean, they are amateurs, but you know what I mean. It's huge. But I wonder whether that kind of buys into a subject that we should do in a definitely in a separate podcast, which is the lost cause of the Confederacy. So lots of people love to, I mean, fascination with the Civil War, I think often does have a sort of political dimension to it in America, rather like that whole ecosystem of plantations and all that sort of stuff. And yeah, I mean, it would be hard as an outsider. I mean,
也许美国听众会不同意并纠正我们。但作为一个局外人，我认为当你穿上邦联制服为奴隶制辩护时，有一个因素在里面。我的意思是，我知道有些人会说，哦，不，州权之类的，但显然，奴隶制是其中很大的一部分。这在目前感觉非常敏感，不是吗？好吧，我的意思是，在英国，关于国家信托基金会以及在多大程度上应该告诉游客那些拥有或建造它的人是否从奴隶制中获利，存在很大的争议。我当时在想，博福特的那些大种植园的情况如何……好吧，我去过一个种植园。
maybe American listeners will disagree and will put us right. But as an outsider, I think there's an element when you're pulling on a Confederate uniform in defense of slavery. I mean, I know some people will say, oh, no, state's rights or whatever, but obviously, slavery is a big part of it. That does feel very highly charged at the moment, doesn't it? Well, I mean, there's a big controversy here in Britain about the National Trust and to what extent visitors should be told about whether people who owned it or built it or whatever, whether they were making their money from slavery. And I was wondering what the state of play is with the grand plantations in Beaufort or... Well, I've been to a plantation.
我去过一个叫布恩霍尔的种植园。带我们参观的是一个绝对的，那种斯嘉丽·奥哈拉式的幻影，她带我们参观了厨房、可爱的客厅、阳台和所有这些东西。但她一次也没提到奴隶制。远处有一堆小屋。
I went to a plantation called Boone Hall. We were shown around by this, absolutely, this sort of vision, this Scarlet O'Hara-like vision, who, you know, took us through the kitchens and the lovely drawing room and the veranda and all this sort of stuff. But she didn't mention slavery once. And there was sort of a load of huts in the distance.
我问，小屋里发生了什么？她说，哦，这就像员工宿舍之类的。你知道，我的意思是，那是几年前的事了。我的意思是，也许他们从那以后改变了他们的说明。但绝对淡化了作为一个游客你会认为最突出的关键因素。显然，我相信很多听众会认为，在不注意其最显著特征的情况下沉浸在这个世界里，确实有点没品位。我甚至在想，即使是像伦敦地牢（London Dungeon）这样的地方，
And I said, what was going on in the huts? And she said, oh, this is like the staff quarters or something. You know, I mean, this was some years ago. I mean, maybe they've changed their rubric since then. But there was definitely a downplaying of the key element that you would think as a visitor would be would be would loom largest and obviously a lot of listeners i'm sure will think there's something kind of really a bit tasteless about luxuriating in this world without drawing attention to its single most salient um feature i wonder even um you know even even something like the London Dungeon,
重点也非常在于折磨、死亡和谋杀。你知道，是开膛手杰克吗？好吧，开膛手杰克，我们请过哈莉·鲁本霍尔德，她非常积极地反对她所认为的“开膛手杰克产业”。这很有趣，
where the emphasis is very much on torture and death and murder. You know, is Jack the Ripper? Well, Jack the Ripper, we had Hallie Rubenhold on, and she's very vigorous in campaigning against what she sees as the Jack the Ripper industry. Which is interesting,
因为当我告诉九岁的儿子我们要和她做播客时，他说，她会告诉我们是谁杀了开膛手杰克吗？我说，不，她更关注女性，那些受害者。他说，谁在乎受害者？福尔摩斯能抓住开膛手杰克吗？开膛手杰克是位王子吗？这是每个人都想得到答案的两个问题。
because when I told my son, who's nine, that we were doing a podcast with her, and he said, is she going to tell us who killed Jack the Ripper? And I said, no, she's more into the women, the victims. And he said, who cares about the victims? Would Sherlock Holmes have caught Jack the Ripper? And was Jack the Ripper a prince? Those are the two questions that everybody wants answered.
每个人都想知道的问题，是的，是的。好吧，我的意思是，我想，我们倾向于重演的事情是暴力的，它们都是暴力的，无论是伦敦地牢里的开膛手杰克，还是战斗重演。你不会重演人们……我的意思是，在某种程度上你会，不是吗？偶尔会有那种尝试，比如汉普郡的那个村庄，他们重建了历史各个时期的各种小屋，你确实会看到人们坐在那里编织之类的，但这本质上没那么戏剧性。它确实没那么戏剧性。如果你把历史作为一个产业来更广泛地评判，
The questions everyone wants, yes, yes. Well, I mean i suppose that that the um you know if we the things that tend to get reenacted are violent they are they're all violent whether it whether it whether it's um jack the ripper in uh in in london dungeons or um you know reenactment battles you don't reenact people i suppose i mean to a degree you do don't you occasionally there are the kind of um attempts to there's that village in um hampshire where they've rebuilt um various huts from various periods of history and you do get people who kind of sit around and weave and things but it's it's less inherently dramatic it is less dramatic. And if you judge history as an industry more broadly,
比如你想到电影，还有书籍，经典畅销的是第二次世界大战和都铎王朝。都铎王朝的迷人之处在于人们被砍头。我的意思是，这就是人们喜欢这个故事的原因。它不仅仅是关于礼服和圣经。是的，它是关于处决。处决者的行为是成功的关键，而且你知道，我们现在看角斗士
so you think about films, but also books, I mean, classically what sells is the Second World War and the Tudors. And the fascination of the Tudors is that people have their heads cut off. I mean, that's what people like about the story. It's not just about kind of gowns and Bibles. Yes, it is about the execution. The the executioners acts as key to the success and and you know we look now at gladiatorial
比赛，我的意思是，我们必须做一期关于角斗士比赛的播客，但我们现在带着恐惧看角斗士比赛，我相信你会说是因为我们的基督教传统，我们对血腥的场面感到反感，但我们却在间接地消费这种血腥。我的意思是，我们马上要谈电子游戏了，但我们在书中消费它。我的意思是，现在有多少作者，有多少历史学家正在创作一个有一千人惨死的章节？是的。
games i mean we will have to do a podcast on gladiatorial games but we look now gladiatorial games with horror i'm sure you would say because of our christian heritage and we recoil from the spectacle of the blood and all the rest of it but we consume the blood don'ticariously. I mean, we're going to do video games in a second, but we consume it in the books. I mean, how many authors right now, how many historians are crafting a chapter in which a thousand people die horribly? Yeah.
人们会为了娱乐而阅读它，实际上。没错。你提到了电脑游戏，确实还有棋盘游戏。很多有历史背景的游戏确实涉及大量的人被杀，但你知道，它可能只是棋盘上的一个棋子移动，整个大陆被征服，或者在电脑游戏中，你攻占一座城市之类的。但让我们进入那个话题，
And we're going to read it for, people are going to read it for entertainment, effectively. Right. And you mentioned computer games and indeed board games. And an awful lot of those that have a kind of historical setting absolutely do involve lots and lots of people being killed but it you know it'll be it could be a counter moving across a board and you know entire continents are conquered or in a computer game you know you storm a city or something but let's let's let's get on to that
休息之后，棋盘游戏和电脑游戏。无广告收听、加更节目和抢先体验现场门票。前往 therestlesentertainment.com。网址是 therestlesentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在谈论作为娱乐的历史，特别是游戏。多米尼克，你以谈论《大富翁》开始了这一集。我确实这样做了，厚颜无耻地。所以《大富翁》，那严格来说是关于历史的游戏吗？那不是关于资本主义的游戏吗？它实际上是。
um after the break uh board games and computer games. Add free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets. Head to therestlesentertainment.com. That's therestlesentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Restless History. We're talking about history as entertainment, particularly games. And Dominic, you opened this episode by talking about Monopoly. I did, shamelessly. So Monopoly, is that strictly a game about history? Isn't it a game about capitalism? It's actually, it is.
好吧，它是关于特定版本资本主义的游戏。它是一个植根于历史的游戏。所以关于《大富翁》的起源有各种各样的争论。但据我们所知，它始于1903年左右。它是一个反资本主义的游戏。它被称为“乔治主义”游戏。美国有一个叫亨利·乔治的人，他有关于地主制、反对地主制的所有理论。所以这是美国的进步时代，人们正在驯服资本主义的过度行为，比如卡内基，那种猖獗的铁路
Well, it's a game about a particular version of capitalism. And it is a historically rooted game. So there are all sorts of arguments about the origins of Monopoly. But as far as we can tell, it began in about 1903. And it was an anti-capitalist game. It was what's called a Georgist game. So there was a guy called Henry George in America who had all these theories about landlordism, about fighting landlordism. So this is the progressive era in America where people are sort of taming the excesses of capitalism, of the sort of Carnegie, you know, sort of rampant railroad
美国式资本主义。而《大富翁》的意义在于说明地主制有多糟糕。换句话说，如果你拥有所有这些财产，你就可以压榨你的租户，你会变得富有，而他们永远不会赢。这就是它的意义所在，如果你不得到所有这些，你永远不会赢，
kind of American school of capitalism. And the point of monopoly was to illustrate how bad landlordism is. So in other words, if you've got all this property, you can squeeze your tenants and you'll become rich and they will never win. That was the point of it, that you would never win if you didn't get all this, you know,
你没有得到所有这些财产。然后基本上《大富翁》演变了，关于它的专利有一场大仗。它最终被玩具公司接手，并在大萧条时期变成了资本主义游戏。所以它不再是向你展示它有多邪恶。
you didn't get all this property. And then basically monopoly evolved and was, there was a big battle over the, the, the patents for it. And it ended up being taken up by the sort of toy companies and turned into a capitalist game in the depression. So it's no longer about showing you how evil it is.
现在它是关于沉浸在其中，沉浸在你的胜利中。显然，从那时起它就一直很成功，但有趣的是，它是一个在政治上不断被重新诠释的游戏。所以有冷战时期的共产主义版本，我们的一些听众寄来了，有一个由东德异见人士制作的版本叫“官僚大富翁”（Bureaucratopoly），它是在嘲讽东德体制。然后是匈牙利共产主义者，我的意思是，他们有自己的版本叫“精明预算”（Budget Smartly）。现在，匈牙利语的实际标题是 Gazdal Kodj Okasan，
Now it's about glorying in it, glorying in your winnings. And obviously it's been longer about showing you how evil it is now it's about glorying in it glorying in your winnings and obviously it's been very successful since then but what's interesting is it is the game that's permanently been reinterpreted politically so there were cold war kind of communist versions and some of our listeners sent in there was a version done by east german dissidents called bureaucratopoly which was mocking the East German system. And then the Hungarian communists, I mean, they had a version of their own called Budget Smartly. Now, the actual title in Hungarian is Gazdal Kodj Okasan,
我的马扎尔语。我们需要乔纳森·威尔逊在这里。我们确实需要。他会纠正我的。毫无疑问。所以，是的，《大富翁》本身就是一个伟大的——我的意思是，大概我们的《大富翁》历史学家将其视为20世纪的地图。
as my magia. We need Jonathan Wilson here. We do, yeah. He would put me right. There's no doubt about that. So, yes, a monopoly in itself is a great – I mean, presumably our historians of Monopoly who see it as a sort of map of the 20th century.
好吧，这意味着它最初是一个反资本主义的棋盘游戏，但很快它就变成了关于征服敌人并变得尽可能富有和强大。是的，像大多数游戏一样。关于这个主题，我们有一个来自名字很棒的“斧头迪克”（Dick of Axe）的问题，他说，从《文明》到《风险》，再到《欧陆风云》，人类似乎有一种不可抗拒的冲动，想要把
Okay, so the implication of that is that it begins as an anti-capitalist board game, but very rapidly it becomes all about conquering your enemies and becoming as rich and powerful as possible. Yeah, like most games. And on that theme we have a question from the splendidly named dick of axe and he says um from civilization to risk to europa universalist there is some irresistible urge in humans it seems to paint
地图涂成一种颜色。无论你是在玩棋盘游戏还是你是罗马皇帝，你同意吗？我的意思是，当谈到棋盘游戏和电脑游戏时，历史主题的游戏大体上似乎确实涉及大量的征服。它们是关于征服的。听到那个问题我才想到，我相信“棋盘游戏去殖民化”运动可能很快就会到来。
a map one color doesn't matter if you're playing a ball game or if you're roman emperor do you agree i mean definitely when it comes when it comes to both the board games and computer games, historically themed games by and large do seem to involve an awful lot of conquest. They are about conquest. It only just occurred to me hearing that question that I'm sure the movement to decolonize board games can only be a mess away.
是的，好吧，你必须说。因为，我的意思是，《风险》、《外交》，所有这些棋盘游戏，它们都是关于建立帝国的，不是吗？
Yeah, well, you've got to say. Because, I mean, risk, diplomacy, all these kindize board games can only be, because I mean, risk, um, diplomacy, all these kinds of board games, they're all about creating empires, aren't they?
以及击败和打击你的对手。我的意思是，很难想象一个不涉及这些的游戏，因为那是游戏的乐趣所在。好吧，即使是国际象棋。我的意思是，国际象棋是在复制一场战斗，不是吗？
And defeat and smiting your opponents. I mean, it's hard to imagine a game that didn't involve that because that's the, that's the pleasure of games. Well, even chess. I mean, chess is kind of replicating a battle, isn't it?
它最初是战车。即使在我们现在玩的这个版本中，它也是在模拟一场战斗，不是吗？最初是战车，即使在我们现在玩的这个版本中，它也是关于战场上的骑士之类的。所以《风险》是其中的经典例子。所以它是一个全球游戏。是的。背景据说是拿破仑时代的。但它有点像冷战游戏，你不觉得吗？
It's originally it's chariots. And even in, in, in, in the one we have now, it's kind of nightsicating a battle, isn't it? Originally, it's chariots, and even in the one we have now, it's kind of knights and things on battlefields. So Risk is the classic example of that. So it's a global game. Yeah. So the setting is supposedly Napoleonic. But it's kind of a Cold War game, don't you think?
它是一种二战后的游戏。它是一个游戏。你是对的，背景有点像冷战游戏，你不觉得吗？你知道，它是一种，或者二战后的游戏。它是一个游戏，你是对的，背景有点老，但你不觉得心态是，你知道，有巨大的集团在争夺世界的控制权吗？是的，卡片显示了，你知道，好奇的耳朵和拿破仑时代的步兵之类的，但你必须征服整个地球，地图就是地球。我，关于我们做的那期关于历史教训的播客，我们非常强调
It's a sort of post-World War II game. It's a game. You're right, the setting is kind of a Cold War game, don't you think? You know, it's a sort of, or post-World War II game. It's a game, you're right, the setting is kind of older, but don't you think the mindset is, you know, there are great blocs fighting each other for control of the world? Yes, the cards show, you know, Curious Ears and the Polarionic Infantrymen and things, but you're having to conquer the entire globe and the map is the globe and i'm um that episode we did on the lessons of history and we dwelt very strongly
不要入侵亚洲，我记得我们总是玩，我和我兄弟玩《风险》，他后来当然去主持了我们关于二战的姐妹播客，是一位非常杰出的二战历史学家，他总是入侵亚洲，所以我总是赢，我总是赢，我总是鼓励他说，你不打算入侵亚洲吗？哦，是的，我想我会的。我认为那种创伤导致了他去研究第二次世界大战。那是对你兄弟心理的一个可怕的洞察。但这些游戏，你见过的。几年前，尼尔·弗格森与一家游戏公司合作，他发表了几篇文章说他要在
on don't invade asia and i remember we always played i played risk with my brother who's since gone on of course to um host our sister pod about the second world war and a very distinguished historian in the second world war um and he would always invade asia and so i'd always win i'd always win i'd always i'd always kind of encourage him say aren't you going to invade asia oh yes i think i will um and i think the trauma of that is what has led him to study the second world war that's a terrible insight into your brother's psychology but these games you've've seen. Now, a few years ago, Neil Ferguson, who had a link-up with the games company, he published a few articles saying that he was going to use this game
哈佛的教学中使用这个游戏。而且这个游戏，我不记得是什么游戏了。我不认为那是一个非常成功的游戏，实际上，他与它合作，而且它对于指导你了解治国之道非常有用。很多时候，对于大多数历史学家来说，这引起了怀疑的哄笑和蔑视。但我实际上认为游戏是一种非常好的方式，我的意思是，这就是为什么中央情报局和五角大楼进行战争游戏的原因，因为他们认为这是说明战争和外交中决定成功或失败的不同变量的好方法。所以你提到了外交。我认为《外交》是最好的。所以那是第一次世界大战的积累。
in his teaching at Harvard. And that this game, I can't remember what game it was. I don't think it was a terribly successful game, actually, that he had collaborated with it and that it was very useful for instructing you about how statecraft worked. And a lot of the time, for most historians, there were kind of guffaws of disbelief and sort of scorn. But I actually think games are incredibly good way of, I mean, that's why the CIA and that's why the Pentagon do war games, because they think they're a good way of illustrating the different variables that condition success or failure in war and in diplomacy. So you said diplomacy. I think diplomacy is the best. So that's the build up to the First World War.
它是欧洲的大国。它之所以伟大是因为你不是轮流进行回合。你们都在同一时间进行。而且在背后捅盟友一刀的机会是巨大的。我玩过它，并成功地在背后捅了我所谓的盟友一刀，以至于我取得了胜利。从那以后我就没玩过，因为我知道我永远无法超越那次。那太棒了。但你看，你在游戏中展现了真实的自我，汤姆，我想是的。是的，你确实展现了，这很令人担忧。是的，但有一些很棒的游戏。所以，是谁，
It's the great powers of Europe. And the reason that's great is that you don't take it in turns to have turns. You all do it at the same time. And the opportunity to stab your allies in the back is tremendous. And I played it and stabbed my supposed ally in the back so successfully that I won triumphantly. And I've never played it since because I know I can never top that. That's great. But you see, you reveal your true self in a game tom i think so um yes you do that's very worrying yes but there's some amazing games so uh who was it
安德鲁·门克斯建议了一个叫《北非战役》的游戏。这是一个了不起的游戏，因为它是一个70年代的游戏，它极其详细。要玩完这个游戏，它是二战北非战役，玩完它估计需要1500小时，游戏本身建议62天。游戏建议每一方需要5个人，其中一个是总司令，其他人是下属。它太复杂了，如果你扮演意大利人，你需要带水给你的意大利面到战场上。是的，你知道，我喜欢那个，我喜欢那个。而且，我的意思是，我查了一篇关于这个的文章，显然那个规则甚至在事实上都不准确，因为发明这个游戏的人说，现实是意大利人用番茄煮他们的意大利面。
andrew menkes suggested a game called the campaign for north africa now this is an amazing game because it's a 70s game it's colossally detailed to play this game through so it's the world war two north african campaign to play it through it takes an estimated 1500 hours and the game itself recommends 62 days the game recommends that on each side you need five people one of whom is the commander-in-chief and the other is subordinate and it's so complicated if you're playing as the italians you need to bring water for your pasta to the battlefield yes you know i i love that i love that and and um apparently so i looked up an article on this um and apparently that rule isn't even factually accurate because the guy who who invented this game he says the reality is that the italians cook their pasta with the tomato
安德鲁·门克斯推荐了一款名为《北非战役》的游戏，这是一款令人惊叹的游戏，因为它诞生于70年代，细节极其丰富。要玩完这款模拟二战北非战役的游戏，预计需要1500个小时，游戏本身建议耗时62天。游戏建议每一方需要五个人，其中一人担任总司令，其他人担任下属。它非常复杂，如果你扮演意大利人，你甚至需要把煮意大利面的水带到战场上。是的，我知道，我喜欢这一点，我喜欢这一点。而且，嗯，显然我查过一篇关于这个的文章，显然那条规则甚至在事实上都不准确，因为发明这个游戏的人说，现实情况是意大利人用番茄来煮他们的意大利面。
sauce that came with the cans wow he. He's done his research. Yeah. And the other amazing thing, he says, every game turn, 3% of your fuel evaporates unless you're the British before a certain date because they used 50-gallon drums instead of jerry cans. Oh, my God. See, there's a level of detail, isn't there? A friend of mine has a game called Twilight Struggle, which is a Cold War game.
罐头附带的酱汁，哇，他。他做了很多研究。是的。另一个令人惊叹的地方是，他说，每一轮游戏，如果你不是在特定日期之前的英国人，你3%的燃料就会蒸发，因为他们用的是50加仑的桶而不是杰瑞罐。天哪。你看，这就是细节的程度，不是吗？我的一个朋友有一个叫《暮光斗争》的游戏，那是一个冷战游戏。
And whenever we go to visit, he always says, you know, is this the moment where we're going to play this game? We've got kids, we've got wives. It's kind of hard to find the moment to say, for the next 10 hours, we'll be in Communicado. But it's more than 10 hours, isn't it? I mean, those games with kind of instruction manuals that are about 200 pages long.
每当我们去拜访时，他总是说，你知道，这是我们玩这个游戏的时刻吗？我们有孩子，有妻子。很难找到一个时刻说，接下来的10个小时，我们将与世隔绝。但不仅仅是10个小时，对吧？我是说，那些说明书大约有200页长的游戏。
Yeah. I mean, it's not as bad as um the the north african campaign but i mean they they are pretty long having said that there are i so there's another question from ben jones and he says i think my entire knowledge of english geography aristocratic families and certainly the plantagenet family tree is from the board game kingmaker always ended with stalemate until the constable of the tower of london got sent to Rye. Did you ever play Kingmaker? No, I've seen it.
是的。我是说，它不像北非战役那么糟糕，但它们确实很长。话虽如此，本·琼斯还有另一个问题，他说，我想我对英国地理、贵族家庭，当然还有金雀花家族谱系的全部了解都来自棋盘游戏《国王制造者》，总是以僵局告终，直到伦敦塔的警卫被派往莱伊。你玩过《国王制造者》吗？没有，我见过。
I wanted it as a child, but I never got it. So that's set against the War of the Roses. Right, yeah, which is itself a colossal game, isn't it? I mean... It is a colossal, yes. Yeah, inspiration of Game of Thrones. So you have to fight, but also you have plagues and you have peasants' revolts
我小时候想要，但我从来没得到过。所以那是以玫瑰战争为背景的。对，是的，它本身就是一个巨大的游戏，不是吗？我是说……它确实是一个巨大的游戏，是的。是的，是《权力的游戏》的灵感来源。所以你必须战斗，但你也有瘟疫和农民起义。
and you have to issue writs to summon parliament. So it's actually quite good. You can go around collecting, you know, Warden of the Sink Ports and Warden of the Northern Marches and things like that. That's a card I've always wanted to have. It's a fabulous game. Yeah.
你必须发布传票来召集议会。所以它实际上相当不错。你可以四处收集，你知道，辛克港总督和北部边境总督之类的东西。那是我一直想拥有的卡片。这是一个绝妙的游戏。是的。
That wiles away a very pleasant three hours. But, you know, the terrible thing, though, Tom, is when you get older. So I finished writing my most recent book about a month ago, and as my reward to myself, because obviously we're stuck at home in lockdown, as my reward to myself, I bought a video game for my computer,
那消磨了非常愉快的三个小时。但是，你知道，可怕的事情是，汤姆，当你变老的时候。所以我大约一个月前写完了我最近的书，作为给自己的奖励，因为显然我们被困在家里封锁，作为给自己的奖励，我为我的电脑买了一个电子游戏，
a strategy game that I could play while my wife was working. And it's called Kaiser Reich. And it's a sort of offshoot of the Hearts of Iron games. So it's set in a world where Germany won the first world war. And it's set in the 1930s. Oh, Dominic, that's your kind of dream. It is, it is. And you can choose any of these.
一个我可以在妻子工作时玩的游戏。它叫《凯撒帝国》。它是《钢铁雄心》游戏的一个分支。所以它设定在一个德国赢得了第一次世界大战的世界里。而且设定在20世纪30年代。哦，多米尼克，那是你的梦想。确实，确实。你可以选择任何这些。
I think there is some sort of slightly politically dodgy elements to it. But anyway, you can choose any country to control. So Britain has become a socialist republic. Austria-Hungary has become a kind of United States, a greater Austria. And I looked at this, I saw the map, and I saw the sort of list. I thought, brilliant, I cannot wait. And I loaded it up and I deleted it about 10 minutes later.
我想它有一些稍微政治上棘手的元素。但无论如何，你可以选择任何国家来控制。所以英国已经变成了一个社会主义共和国。奥匈帝国已经变成了一种合众国，一个大奥地利。我看了这个，我看到了地图，我看到了列表。我想，太棒了，我迫不及待了。我加载了它，大约10分钟后我就删除了它。
Why? Because you have to produce a lot of steel. It's so complicated. I knew I'd never come to. And I started to read manuals online and people's advice about how to play it. And I just thought, I don't understand what they're saying. And I don't have enough hours.
为什么？因为你必须生产大量的钢铁。它太复杂了。我知道我永远也搞不懂。我开始在线阅读手册和人们关于如何玩它的建议。我只是想，我不明白他们在说什么。而且我没有足够的时间。
Life is too short. So what about the grand idea of those kind of ones, which is civilization? Yeah, I have played that. So you begin with a tribe of hunter-gatherers in whatever it is, 4000 BC. You do. You create your civilization from scratch. You create a civilization and then you have to send a space rocket to Alpha Centauri. And you can be any one of a number of civilizations.
生命太短暂了。那么那些宏大的游戏，比如《文明》，怎么样？是的，我玩过那个。所以你从公元前4000年的狩猎采集部落开始。确实。你从零开始创造你的文明。你创造一个文明，然后你必须发射太空火箭到半人马座阿尔法星。你可以成为众多文明中的任何一个。
And what it does, which is what all these games do, is they sort of mirror all those books that you see, which will say, you know, these are the 10 building blocks of a successful nation state, or this is how democracies live and how they die. So I always think they're slightly a bit like business books. They try to sort of turn history into a set of distinct variables. And that's
它所做的是，所有这些游戏都做的事情，它们有点像你看到的那些书，上面会说，你知道，这是一个成功的民族国家的10个基石，或者这就是民主如何生存以及它们如何消亡。所以我总是认为它们有点像商业书籍。它们试图把历史变成一组不同的变量。而这
obviously how the game works the game works on variables and they say these are the building blocks of civilization now create your own and it is very they are very addictive um but they're sort of they're turning history into a kind of massive spreadsheet aren't they to some extent but they have to don't they because otherwise it doesn't work but it's very very deterministic i mean it's kind of marism, absolute power of 10. And it's also very, I mean, you know, you talked about decolonizing games. I mean, it establishes the emergence of European civilization as absolutely the norm that you have to industrialize.
显然是游戏运作的方式，游戏基于变量运作，他们说这些是文明的基石，现在创造你自己的，它们非常令人上瘾，嗯，但它们有点把历史变成了一种巨大的电子表格，不是吗？在某种程度上，但它们必须这样做，不是吗？否则它就无法运作，但它非常非常具有决定论色彩，我的意思是，这有点像马克思主义，绝对权力的10。而且它也非常，我的意思是，你知道，你谈到了游戏的去殖民化。我的意思是，它确立了欧洲文明的崛起绝对是必须工业化的规范。
And then you have to colonize everybody else. And then you have to colonize everybody else. And that is the pattern of... So there's an even better example of a game like that, Tom, which is, I think, the aficionados prefer to civilization, which is called Europa Universalis, which I highly recommend. So Europa Universalis starts in about 1450 and you can play till the Battle of Waterloo.
然后你必须殖民其他人。然后你必须殖民其他人。这就是……的模式。所以有一个更好的例子，汤姆，我认为爱好者们比《文明》更喜欢它，它叫《欧陆风云》，我强烈推荐。所以《欧陆风云》大约从1450年开始，你可以一直玩到滑铁卢战役。
And what that does is you choose your country that exists in 1450 or so and then the game follows history. So the Reformation happens and the 30 Years' War breaks out and set events follow each other. But also there are set technological and cultural developments, which are quite Eurocentric. Oh, no, I really want to play this. Which you have to, but you have to.
它所做的是你选择你在1450年左右存在的国家，然后游戏跟随历史。所以宗教改革发生了，三十年战争爆发了，设定的事件一个接一个。但也有设定的技术和文化发展，它们相当欧洲中心主义。哦，不，我真的很想玩这个。你必须，但你必须。
You get penalised if you don't embrace the printing press or if you don't embrace colonization, then your stability cost is increased or whatever. So in other words, you have to follow the sort of... Down the funnel. does reproduce in a way that maybe, you know, an academic seminar can't, the strategic dilemmas, shall we say, of leading a state. You know, if you are Prussia or you are Poland, in a weird way, kind of role-playing it, I think does bring home the difficulties more so than reading it in the most, you know, the most beautifully researched monograph. There is a sense in which role-playing in that way does kind of carry a charge. So those computer games, part of the fun is obviously
如果你不拥抱印刷机或者如果你不拥抱殖民，你就会受到惩罚，那么你的稳定成本就会增加等等。所以换句话说，你必须跟随那种……顺着漏斗走。确实以一种学术研讨会可能无法做到的方式重现了领导国家的战略困境，我们可以这么说。你知道，如果你是普鲁士或者你是波兰，以一种奇怪的方式，角色扮演它，我认为确实比在最，你知道，最精心研究的专著中阅读它更能让人体会到困难。在某种意义上，以那种方式进行角色扮演确实带有一种冲击力。所以那些电脑游戏，乐趣的一部分显然是
absolutely being funneled down the spout of history. So to an extent, not being able to divert from it generates the fun. But then in other ways, that is precisely the fun, is being able to havege from it is you know generates the fun but then in other ways that is precisely the fun is being able to have aztecs fight yeah absolutely or whatever um yeah that's the incongruity there's um there's a i i've never been able to work out whether it's true or not um but this story that gandhi in, who is incredibly pacifist and never declares war on anyone, when they reach the nuclear age, there's some glitch, set civilizations, and making them behave in holy, unexpected ways. Exactly. Martin Luther King becoming dictator of the United States or something would be very interesting.
绝对是被漏斗引导着走过历史的喷口。所以在某种程度上，不能偏离它产生了乐趣。但在其他方面，这正是乐趣所在，能够拥有阿兹特克人战斗，是的，绝对，或者其他什么，嗯，是的，这就是不协调之处，嗯，有一个，我从来没能弄清楚它是否是真的，嗯，但这个故事说甘地，他是一个极其和平主义者，从不向任何人宣战，当他们到达核时代时，有一些故障，设定文明，并使它们以神圣、意想不到的方式行事。正是如此。马丁·路德·金成为美国独裁者之类的会非常有趣。
Which I suppose is a kind of counterfactual, the kind of counterfactuals that you do when you create alternative timelines in history. Sort of silly. But the other kind of game that you have is a game that plunges you into history in a sort of individual level. So that's, say, the Assassin's Creed games or Call of Duty. Call of Duty is all about – it's basically Second World War reenactment fantasy, isn't it? Yeah, it's about killing people. But Assassin's Creed is more interesting.
我想这是一种反事实，当你创造历史中的替代时间线时，你所做的反事实。有点傻。但你拥有的另一种游戏是让你以某种个人层面沉浸在历史中的游戏。所以，比如，《刺客信条》游戏或《使命召唤》。《使命召唤》全是关于——它基本上是第二次世界大战重演幻想，不是吗？是的，它是关于杀人。但《刺客信条》更有趣。
And I'm surprised that you've never played it, Tom, because a lot of it is set in kind of ancient Egypt, ancient Greece, and all that sort of thing. The reason I haven't tried it is the same reason that i haven't taken up crack i'm sure it's brilliant everybody says it's brilliant but i know that i would never get anything done yeah it's true you know i could sit in the back or i could or i could kind of be your children are too old now you see my son is nine so he's perfectly you know he's the right age to be really into all those even though they're 10 18 certificate yeah we've just we've just been fighting um in the peloponnesian war
我很惊讶你从来没玩过它，汤姆，因为其中很多设定在古埃及、古希腊以及所有这类事情中。我没试过的原因和我没沾染毒品的原因一样，我相信它很棒，每个人都说它很棒，但我知道我永远也做不成任何事，是的，这是真的，你知道，我可以坐在后面，或者我可以，或者我可以，你的孩子现在太大了，你看，我儿子九岁，所以他非常，你知道，他是真正喜欢所有这些的合适年龄，尽管它们是18岁限制，是的，我们刚刚一直在战斗，嗯，在伯罗奔尼撒战争中。
very entertaining oh god i had to do an article about i had to do an article in january about um vikings and why they were culturally cool and that was on the back of the release of the new assassin's creed which is set in the viking world and i i thought should i um should i get it and i almost did and then i went and watched i watched the opening loop on youtube instead and it was kind of like methadone i got a vague sense of it but i wasn't wasn't surrendering to it but you see all these games are quite political in a way because they're all about i mean they're all about fighting they're all about sort of individual agency um and the sort of you know there is this sort of uh conspiracy theory that underplays them all so you know the world is being controlled by the templars and stuff so actually it looks back to
非常有趣，哦天哪，我一月份不得不写一篇关于维京人以及为什么他们在文化上很酷的文章，那是基于新《刺客信条》的发布，它设定在维京世界，我，我想我应该，嗯，我应该买它吗？我差点就买了，然后我去看，我看了YouTube上的开场循环，它有点像美沙酮，我有一种模糊的感觉，但我没有沉迷于它，但你看到所有这些游戏在某种程度上都很政治化，因为它们全是关于，我的意思是，它们全是关于战斗，它们全是关于某种个人能动性，以及那种，你知道，有一种阴谋论在它们之下，所以你知道，世界正被圣殿骑士团之类的东西控制，所以实际上它回顾了
our podcast about conspiracy theories because the games present as all games do, because they have to, there's a rule book and there's an intelligence that kind of underpins them and binds them all together. So actually what they miss from history is the sort of, is it worth the unexpected, the, you know,
我们关于阴谋论的播客，因为游戏呈现出所有游戏都会呈现的东西，因为它们必须这样做，有一本规则书，有一种智慧在某种程度上支撑着它们并将它们结合在一起。所以实际上它们从历史中遗漏的是那种，值得吗？意想不到的，你知道，
the messiness, I suppose they simplify history, don't they? They make it consumable, but you still enjoy it. Oh yeah. I mean mean of course but then but i mean games are uh games are part of human nature aren't they i mean as you know we
混乱，我想它们简化了历史，不是吗？它们使它变得可消费，但你仍然享受它。哦，是的。我的意思是，当然，但我的意思是游戏是，嗯，游戏是人性的一部分，不是吗？我的意思是，如你所知，我们
love games but also the what assassin's creed does for example is it you know they would have in their game about um setting kind of cleopatra's egypt they've got this incredibly faithful or painstaking reenactment of what Alexandria would look like. And you do get a set. I mean, I've never seen anything that's given me. And sometimes you can find online videos of people, you know, they've got ancient historians to comment. I suppose they haven't asked you, Tom.
喜欢游戏，而且《刺客信条》所做的，例如，它，你知道，他们会在关于，嗯，设定某种克利奥帕特拉的埃及的游戏中，他们有这种令人难以置信的忠实或艰苦的重演，亚历山大港会是什么样子。你确实得到了一套。我的意思是，我从来没见过任何东西给了我。有时你可以在网上找到人们的视频，你知道，他们有古代历史学家来评论。我想他们没问过你，汤姆。
They get ancient historians to comment on the design of Athens or the design of Rome and to say, how accurate accurate is this so i looked at london viking london right um i thought it'd be inaccurate did you that's disappointing it was it was like a very fresh rome room with lots of roman statues standing everywhere i think that's and you don't think that's right you don't that's right i don't i don't but having said that i thought it't think that's right? No, I don't. I don't. But having said that, I thought it was amazing. I mean, you kind of feel that in a fantasy, that is what abandoned Rome in London should look like. Yeah.
他们让古代历史学家评论雅典的设计或罗马的设计，并说，这有多准确？所以我看了伦敦，维京伦敦，对吧，嗯，我以为它会不准确，你觉得吗？那令人失望，它就像一个非常新鲜的罗马房间，到处都是罗马雕像，我想那是，而且你不认为那是对的，你不认为那是对的，我不，我不，但话虽如此，我认为它很棒。我的意思是，你有点觉得在幻想中，这就是伦敦被遗弃的罗马应该看起来的样子。是的。
And that must be part of the fun, because I don't want to play a computer game where everything is absolutely... No, I suppose not. You know, you want a degree of creativity and experiment. But the other extent to which they're political is that I look slightly askance at the Vikings one because I believe the English are the baddies. So Alfred the Great is...
那一定是乐趣的一部分，因为我不想玩一个电脑游戏，其中一切都绝对……不，我想不是。你知道，你想要一定程度的创造力和实验。但它们政治化的另一个程度是，我稍微怀疑维京人的那个，因为我相信英国人是坏人。所以阿尔弗雷德大帝是……
King Alfred is the baddie, apparently. Yeah, he's the main baddie. That's what decided me not to get it. I'm not lending my support to that. It's a French company, isn't it? So, you know, you suspect the worst. French-Canadian, I think. So they'd released a couple of very, very successful games set in the crusades and in the renaissance then they released the third one which was set in the american war of independence and
阿尔弗雷德国王显然是坏人。是的，他是主要的坏人。这就是决定我不买它的原因。我不会支持那个。那是一家法国公司，不是吗？所以，你知道，你怀疑最坏的情况。我想是法裔加拿大人。所以他们发布了几个非常非常成功的游戏，设定在十字军东征和文艺复兴时期，然后他们发布了第三个，设定在美国独立战争中，
you played an american fighting the british and their sales in britain were much worse that moment made me proud to be british to see that statistic that people didn't want to i hope that people in wessex will not be buying this anti-alfredian nonsense but it will be interesting to find out whether people in germany for example are ambivalent about playing war games in which the germans are always painted as the i mean they're always the villains aren't they you're killing nazis i mean that must be a weird thing to do if you're a teenage gamer in frankfurt and you're basically engaged in shooting you know people who are mocked up versions of your great-grandfather and his buddies yeah do you not think yeah i do yeah
你扮演一个美国人与英国人战斗，他们在英国的销售额要差得多。那一刻让我为成为英国人感到自豪，看到那个统计数据，人们不想，我希望威塞克斯的人们不会购买这种反阿尔弗雷德的胡言乱语，但了解德国人是否对玩德国人总是被描绘成，我的意思是，他们总是坏人，不是吗？你在杀纳粹，我的意思是，如果你是一个法兰克福的十几岁玩家，而你基本上在射击，你知道，你曾祖父和他的伙伴们的模拟版本，那一定是一件奇怪的事情，对吧？你不是这么想的吗？是的，我确实，是的。
i do i mean that also raises the question that um alan allport who's a historian himself and a listener to the podcast raised raised on Twitter about taste. He said, at what point do you cross the line? And do you think, I mean, the Vikings were incredibly brutal. They enslaved people, bashed their heads in with their axes or whatever. Do you think there's ever a taste issue, Tom? Well, I think that's interesting. I mean, that is an interesting question, which touches on a much broader issue, which is when do atrocities and enslavement and imperial expansion, when does it cease to be a legitimate subject for entertainment?
我确实，我的意思是，这也提出了一个问题，嗯，艾伦·奥尔波特，他本人是一位历史学家，也是播客的听众，在推特上提出了关于品味的问题。他说，你在什么时候越界了？你认为，我的意思是，维京人极其残忍。他们奴役人们，用斧头敲碎他们的头之类的。你认为曾经有过品味问题吗，汤姆？嗯，我认为这很有趣。我的意思是，这是一个有趣的问题，触及了一个更广泛的问题，即暴行、奴役和帝国扩张何时不再是娱乐的合法主题？
Yeah, that's a really good question. I think that is a huge question. And I think that that could be the theme of another episode where we, we discuss that issue. Um, and I think that that is actually the perfect point on which to, um, pack up the board game, put away the dice. Yeah. Leave it hanging.
是的，这是一个非常好的问题。我认为这是一个巨大的问题。而且我认为这可能是另一集的テーマ，我们讨论这个问题。嗯，而且我认为这实际上是打包棋盘游戏、收起骰子的完美点。是的。让它悬而未决。
So thanks ever so much. So, uh, see you next episode. Uh, we'll see you next time. Tom has been, uh,
所以非常感谢。所以，嗯，下一集见。嗯，我们下次见。汤姆一直是，嗯，
crushed. I have conquered the board. Um, I just wanted to get that in actually. And, uh, yeah, we'll see you next time.
被粉碎了。我已经征服了棋盘。嗯，我只是想把那个放进去。而且，嗯，是的，我们下次见。
We've got, um, I can't remember what we've got lined up for next week Persia we've got Persia Persia great well I'm really looking forward to that
我们有，嗯，我不记得我们下周安排了什么，波斯，我们有波斯，波斯，太好了，我真的很期待那个。
what have the Persians ever done for us yeah why why Persia basically has invented everything it's a great episode look forward to it bye alright
波斯人为我们做过什么？是的，为什么，为什么波斯基本上发明了一切？这是一集很棒的节目，期待它，再见，好的。
goodbye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。